[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous - c'est michelle et moi
quentin ce qu'il fait quant à michel et
là votre action vous rappelle
probablement les célèbres success-story
que sont michel et augustin ou jackie et
michel je vois qu'il ya des connaisseurs
de la salle ça fait plaisir
bon trêve de plaisanterie aujourd'hui on
n'est pas venu vous parler de petits
biscuits mais bel et bien de mutation du
marché du travail et on est venu
illustrer ce changement en vous
partageant notre histoire celle de deux
indépendants qui ont décidé de
s'affranchir de tous les codes du
salariat c'est à dire la fin notamment
d'un respect au combien comment sur abl
de la hiérarchie et de la fin des
process des process des process bref
vous allez voir on a tout pour réussir
que vous avez pu remarquer j'ai un petit
accent cet accent c'est pas un accent
toulousain prononcé et encore moins un
accent ch'ti je suis ni en colombie dans
le pays de pablo escobar qu'on les fans
de netflix et des clichés
j'ai vécu en irrigué en argentine
évidemment open crise économique
et ensuite je me suis dit pourquoi pas
parti en inde un des pays les plus
pauvres au monde
bref j'avais tout pour réussir ben moi
contrairement à michel j'ai pas fait le
tour du monde mais je connais très bien
les plus grandes métropoles françaises
et ses plus belles régions le larzac le
cantal est évidemment l'île de france où
j'ai fait toute ma scolarité mais
n'étant pas très bons élèves
eh bien j'ai intégré le plus mauvais
lycée parisien est probablement l'un des
plus mauvais lycée français en terme de
réussite au bac
bref comme michel j'avais tout pour
réussir
deux histoires sans lien parents mais
qui finalement sera ensemble un endroit
très précis
une frustration à l'école comme quand un
mois n'est pas été très bon élève à
l'école
d'ailleurs j'ai failli doubler à
plusieurs reprises je me souviens encore
mon directeur à l'époque me dire bah
qu'il n'avait pas les compétences
nécessaires pour réussir que
n'était pas au niveau et qui me
conseille fortement de redoubler alors
j'avais le choix j'ai choisi continue je
profite de ce moment pour le saluer on
s'est aperçu que le système en fin de
compte ils n'étaient que très peu
collaboratif or la collaboration le
travail en équipe
ça fait clairement partie de ce qu'on
appelle les softs qu'ils aient les soft
skills et les compétences clés à
maîtriser dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
mais évidemment dans le monde de demain
moi les seuls moments où je collaborais
quand j'étais au lycée c'était durant
les contrôles et n'étant pas très bonne
élève
eh bien je regardais à gauche je
regardais à droite
bon bref je triche et de temps en temps
ça marche et puis de temps en temps
j'avais zéro moi j'adorerais collaborer
à l'école alors c'était que pendant les
intérêts et les cours de sport où il
fallait faire des équipes up pour jouer
au foot alors là on colle à bois et
bizarrement l époque on me comparait
avec messi je sais pas pourquoi
bon on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait une
vraie une adéquation entre la production
de savoirs et le marché du travail
24 % 24 % c'est le nombre de jeunes qui
sont au chômage
ça montre bien que l'école elle ne forme
plus aux métiers d'aujourd'hui est
évidemment plus aux métiers de demain et
c'est malheureux parce que cette école l
essence
elle est censée transformer un pays mais
comment est ce que vous voulez
transformer un pays et les méthodes
d'enseignement alors que cette école n'a
pas évolué depuis 250 ans et ça c'est
très bien résumée à travers la slide qui
va défiler non bon ben c'est pas grave
petit problème technique en gros gaspard
of il le dit très très bien il dit que
si une personne des années 60 se
réveiller aujourd'hui ne comprendra rien
il ne comprendra rien parce que tout
aurait changé tout sauf l'éducation
moi ce que j'ai pas aimé de l'école
c'est qu'il vise à sanctionner les
étudiants à travers des notes elles
forment dans les profils standard
ce que nous on appelle les clubs qui
vont débarquer dans le monde du travail
incapable de s'insurger contre la
hiérarchie leur boss leurs process
heureusement il ya un changement est en
train de s'opérer
mais il est lent très lent même trop
lent cette frustration à l'école est
devenue ma source de motivation
quotidien je voulais montrer aux autres
que j'étais capable de faire ce qu' il
n'aurait j'avais une et une seule envie
crémant pour l'entreprise prendre mes
propres choix est mon propre patron et
ne pas suivre ou même subir les
décisions des grands patrons des grands
groupes alors ce chemin a commencé après
l'école là où j'ai choisi de suivre
cession d'entreprise là où les eaux
traitées par défaut moi c'était ma
vocation
ensuite j'ai fait une première
expérience au nahd et pour finir j'ai
décidé d'intégrer le master 2 innovation
management des nouvelles technologies là
où j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir de
rencontrer contre l'ambroisie est là la
connivence
elle a tout de suite sauté aux yeux bien
que nous venions michelle et moi
d'horizons totalement différent on avait
un objectif commun celui de devenir
indépendant mais pour devenir
indépendant il fallait encore une fois
s'affranchir des dernières contraintes
universitaire c'est à dire valider nos
stages et de notre stage on se souvient
beaucoup de choses à commencer par
l'entreprise et le nombre d'entreprises
où nous étions employées à l'époque et
les postes que nous occupions michel il
était chef de projet dans le secteur de
la data et moi j'étais chef de projet
excusez du peu à la direction de
l'innovation
en arrivant je me suis tout de suite
aperçu que c'était très pyramidale très
normé et très pro cessé mais la chance
que j'ai eue c'est que j'avais un tuteur
qui m'a vraiment fait monter en
compétence sur le sujet des nouvelles
méthodologies des nouvelles technologies
et de ce qu'on appelle notamment le
management et les sources qu'ils mais ma
frustration elle venait principalement
que pour chaque projet
il fallait avoir l'accord du n + 1 du n
+ 2 du mp3 u n + 4 duels 2,5
bref de quasiment toute l'entreprise et
donc tous les projets prenais beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et c'est bien
ça enfin compte le problème de ce type
d'entreprises qui sont issus du modèle
fordiste elle applique ce qu'on appelle
le one bestway ça sous-entend qu'il n'ya
évidemment qu'une seule bonne démarche
la bonne ce qui laisse que très peu de
place à votre créativité
en fin de compte les entreprises qu'est
ce qu'elles font elles essayent de faire
pérenniser l'existant en fin de compte
une entreprise elle fait toujours comme
on a toujours fait oui normal elle a
toujours fait comme ça
après les notre stage on sait tout de
suite aperçu que on n'était pas fait
pour la vie de salariat on sait de
retrouver les deux à se poser la même
question au même moment on savait qu'on
voulait créer quelque chose ensemble
mais on savait pas quel chemin de
prendre du coup à l'époque tous les
chemins étaient étaient bons a testé on
a commencé par un très simple trouver
des projets en france et les faire
autour c'est à l'international là où
nous on avait des contacts tous les
contacts nécessaires pour mener à bien
un projet de bout en bout en inde en
espagne au mexique en colombie et en
uruguay et en argentine bref partout
du coup on a commencé à créer des
profils aussi diverses que variées
toutes les plateformes pc
un jour l'un des designers l'autre jour
on était développeurs le troisième jour
on était peintre ensuite on était les
trois en même temps
bref on a créé plein de profil dans
toutes les plateformes qu'on connaissait
mal au beurre à boire
freelance.com bref partout et à vrai
dire ça pas du tout fonctionné
on a eu un premier entretien un deuxième
entretien un troisième entretien et
notamment un entretien qui était très
marrant et aussi qui nous a marqué celui
de monsieur tournesol alors évidemment
mais ce tournesol c'est un pseudonyme
qu'on lui a donnée parce qu'il avait un
côté un peu savant fou comme ce qu'ils
font dans la bd de tintin est donc ce
monsieur tournesol il contacte michel
sur l'une des plateformes et des la
lecture du message
je me suis aperçu et je me suis dit il
ya anguille sous roche mais michel
débordant d'enthousiasmé comme à son
habitude et qui m'a encouragé à aller
aller comme ça on y va du coup qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on y est allé ça a pris
deux heures de train et on est arrivé
dans un bled un petit peu paumé rue des
petits oiseaux et il nous a accueillis
dans son garage qui était selon lui un
haut lieu de l'innovation
bon il y avait simplement une connexion
internet filaire et une imprimante et à
mon avis il avait tronqué sont entamées
sont à tous contre un smartphone depuis
très peu de temps
bon on parle avec lui parce qu'il était
sympathique et en fin de compte on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un besoin qui est
très classique c'est avoir une meilleure
visibilité sur les réseaux sociaux et
construire une stratégie commerciale
très clair donc on continue cette
conversation et à la fin évidemment on
rentre chez nous ça prend deux heures et
avec michel on se regarde et on se dit
mais qui est ce qu'on fout là quoi
qu'est ce qu'on fout là on pourrait
totalement à louer notre temps dans les
tâches à plus forte valeur ajoutée et
surtout à les tâches qu'on aimerait
vraiment faire et du coup on s'est dit
il faut pivoter et c'est ce qu'on a fait
du coup il a complètement changé de
stratégie on se dit pourquoi essayer de
vendre d'autres personnes alors qu'on
sait même pas un point de nous mêmes du
coup on crée de profils spécialisés dans
les nouvelles technologies et les
nouvelles méthodologies et c'est là que
banco c'est a super bien marché on a été
contacté pour animer un workshop dans le
secteur des nouvelles technologies
et comme ça s'est bien passé et bien
nous a rappelé une fois une deuxième
fois et demain qui sait peut-être une
quatrième une cinquième ou une sixième
fois
ces missions étaient vraiment très
intéressante mais aussi très courte ce
qui nous permettait pas d'avoir
finalement une stabilité financière et à
la fin de chaque mois
on se retrouvait à payer un loyer et à
galérer de nouveau à vrai dire on a eu
pas mal de chance parce que après plus
de trente ans après une nouvelle
personne de contact
ce taux longs rencontrer la mission à
culture et une nouvelle commune entre
une grosse entreprise aux nouvelles
technologies et nouvelle méthodologie du
coup nous comme on aime bien faire de
manière très classique de manière très
procès et faire toujours qu'on l'a
toujours fait on s'est pointé à 2 alors
qu'ils attendaient une seule personne et
à vrai dire il a vraiment qui fait cette
démarche qu'il cherchait une personne
différente il en a eu deux et pour vous
illustrer voilà la photo de notre
premier jour on nous a demandé de se
présenter dans les réseaux social de
l'entreprise igamerz de où tout le monde
se présente de manière très classique
nous on s'est présenté comme ça c'est
vrai qu'une photo comme ça normalement
je pense que vous utilisez tous les
réseaux sociaux et il ya beaucoup
d'informations et en règle générale vous
lisez les articles qui vous plaisent le
plus où les photos qui peuvent
éventuellement sortir des habitudes des
traditions et dans l'entreprise dans
laquelle nous étions je peux vous
assurer que ça un peu cassé les codes et
l' avantage c'est que ça nous a permis
en fait d'être identifié et on a gagné
beaucoup de temps alors je sais pas si
ici vous travaillez avec des consultants
indépendants ou non mais certains vont
me dire que le statut de consultant
indépendant ça revêt je dirais un
caractère un petit peu en dessous gènes
du fait de ne pas avoir de salaire
régulier
c'est vrai mais quitte à choisir je
referais exactement la même chose parce
qu'on a vu comment ça se passait dans
les boîtes de conseils classique et donc
il ya une sorte de système de castes
c'est à dire que vous commencez en tant
que consultant junior bien joli terme
en gros vous êtes consultant subalterne
vous travaillez 32 heures sur 24 et
évidemment vous faites tout le staff que
votre manager et votre seniors ne
veulent pas faire au bout de deux ans
quelques nuits blanches et des séances
jusqu'ici vous devenez non pas seniors
mais confirmée alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire confirmé confirmer ça veut
dire que vous confirme dans votre statut
en gros vous allez faire exactement le
même travail mais vous avez devant du un
petit peu plus cher auprès de vos
clients
comment est ce que enfin qu'ensuite en
classique parles tu vas nulle tir michel
alors il parle comme ça on souhaite
obscur et les populations marketing lors
de notre aka tant de manières en
l'utilisant l'agilité le design thinking
de tout ça de manière très frugale bon
avait compris il ya beaucoup de bullshit
évidemment on grossit les traits c'est
le but mais en vrai il ya un petit fond
c'est à dire que le consultant classique
et bah il peut pas choisir sa mission
d'ailleurs qui va aller dans des
missions chez un client et de temps en
temps les missions ne m'intéresse pas du
tout au contraire du consultant
indépendant qui lui va se diriger vers
les missions et les entreprises
évidemment qu'il aime le plus donc en
règle générale il sera meilleur
et évidemment plus productifs notre
histoire finalement n'est qu'un reflet
d'une tendance de marché le chiffre que
vous voyez derrière c'est le nombre de
fréquences qui aujourd'hui en france
plus de 800 mille ans en france ce qui
est intéressant c'est que finalement ce
chiffre a évolué de 130% les derniers 10
dernières années
130 % et ce phénomène s'est pas un
phénomène mad in france
c'est un phénomène qu'on trouve à
l'international on peut donner l'exemple
par exemple deux états unis où la main
d'oeuvre
on estime que pour 2020 50 % de la
main-d'oeuvre sera free lance est ce qui
est encore plus intéressant c'est que
88% 2,10 être par choix et après coup on
pose la question pourquoi pourquoi on
est arrivé ici pourquoi nous comment est
ce qu'on a fait
quel jour on appris pourquoi ne nous pas
finalement on nous avait dit de thé
notre plus jeune âge qu'on n'allait pas
réussir que la réussite n'était pas fait
pour nous alors c'est là où on s'est
rendu compte que la différence
finalement ne se joue pas sur les traces
qu'ils les rats style 2d qui sont prises
on compte ceux dont les notes de l'école
sont plutôt sur les sauf qu'ils aient
voilà dans quatre clés en commençant par
l'humour je suis sûr qu'après cette
terre si je vous dis merci qui merci
quand on est michel vous allez vous
rappelez merci qui encore une fois merci
dit bon on n'est pas ça va s'arrêter si
on était dix humour pour passer de faire
passer des messages
ensuite la créativité la créativité qui
nous permet de trouver des nouvelles de
nouvelles solutions à des problèmes
complexes des solutions innovantes de
pouvoir rebondir sur europe 1 et puis
voté ce qui nous a permis finalement de
se rendre compte que on n'était pas du
tout vers le bon chemin et finalement
trouvé le nôtre ensuite le das le res
qui nous permet de vaincre cette peur
c'est teneur de faire le pas du
freelancing cette peur de savoir quand
on va vers le bon chemin même si on n'a
pas encore atteint et savoir qu'on a un
loyer appuyer la fin du mois cette
audace nous permet de continuer de
continuer vers là où on veut aller et
finalement le collectif et quand je
parle de collective je parle de travail
en équipe et je parle aussi de binômes à
la fin de ce tête chaud quand vous allez
rentrer chez vous pensez à une seule
chose à développer vos soeurs skills
merci
[Applaudissements]